the Joe Rogan experience you see what
Trump tweeted now he tweeted and deleted
it's [ __ ] hilarious
he said checks are coming to everyone in
America except the people who used
hashtag not my president I wouldn't want
to offend you with a cheque from someone
that's not your president you can find
that oh and then it would hatch tag
Magga afterwards I mean he just dunked
on them the president dunks on people
yeah
tweet the leader is someone whose
Department was probably like mr. Trump
that's not a good idea they have a siren
that goes on that yeah I know the
president can delete tweets how much is
he gonna send I think I think they
wanted to give like $1,000 a month or
something like that to Americans is that
the idea Jeremy it's hurt lots of things
I don't know up to 2030 saying they
should give 2,000 a month yeah everybody
but if you give everybody $2,000 a month
it's a good thing but everyone's gonna
go hey you could have done this the
whole time that's right
what do you wait a minute if you just
raise taxes can you just give people
money can just give people more money
and if I'm not saying we should do this
but imagine that was a solution to all
this if you just give people more money
everything just sort of levels out and
relaxes it drops whimsy drops drug abuse
drops well I mean they've got to know
that when people don't have work they
don't have money with no money they
can't support their family that's when
the riots start yes
that you just catch on fire they know
that so that it's like a bribe to try to
keep people from rioting until whatever
the [ __ ] war is passed you could look at
it that way or it's giving people a
different environment to exist in one
that doesn't leave them hostile so
instead of looking at it like a bribe
look at it like you don't want I see
what a lot of your problem is we're not
you're not asking for affluence you
could barely get by but if it was easy
to get by if you could just get by and
then you could pursue other things would
that be better for society and that was
like what Andrew yang was suggesting if
this whole automation
revolution took place and everything
started getting automated and no one had
a job anymore
there might be something to that there
might be something that now even you
know the question is like what are what
are you happy your your taxes get used
for you know it's almost like you should
be able to vote on that like the one
thing that we don't get real direction
on right like in terms of like what the
country actually wants but if we could
all just individually vote on things
like that like where's where's my taxes
go I write my tax didn't go 100% to
education right I want to make that cut
and you know you guys get a figure out
what to do with the rest of the money
maybe did not money I wanted to go
towards education but then nobody there
the people who would be paying for war
and prisons and [ __ ] would just be like
BDSM people how about the salaries how
about the salaries of politicians about
the money then we go to tours private
jets yeah it's [ __ ] crazy also like
the loose connection between the state
and corporations the way it's just all
kind of merging together right now and
also you know it appears to be kind of
the apocalypse at the moment like well
it's it's if it's not the apocalypse I
don't think it's the apocalypse I think
it's just a dangerous dangerous illness
but it's definitely a dress rehearsal
it's a dress rehearsal for [ __ ]
people gonna become Preppers it is gonna
be amazing for the toilet paper industry
they're gonna they're gonna experience a
banner year they say you got toilet
paper stock you're riding high right now
do you remember the I don't know if you
if you had this experience but like I
can remember sitting at my computer and
pressing the button on Amazon where I
wanted to buy something and it's like
this isn't available right now it's my
button that brings me things it didn't
like suddenly just realizing oh my
[ __ ] god how completely weak if I
become that I got accustomed to pressing
this button and people would bring
groceries to my house yeah and now they
don't now it's like stop
it's not only that I'm so accustomed to
like well you know I'll just go to the
grocery store and pick up some food it's
always been there it's not there dude I
had an insta cart delivery today you
know cuz we wanted to get stock up on
food two hundred two hours worth of food
guess what I got strawberries
hummus and I think we got like I don't
know some like eggs that's it out of the
whole order everything else was sold out
all the beef gone all the chicken gone
nothing's there it's like the the
shelves are empty so it's like okay send
everybody two thousand dollars a month
but what are they gonna buy if there's
like no food on the shelves like what I
think that was a temporary freakout
where people stockpiled stuff and I
think as long as food keeps getting
delivered on a normal schedule
I think that'll normal out I hope I did
I do
I think that'll normal out but it just
shows you there's so many things in our
society that are amazing like grocery
stores like cell phones like we can call
each other all this too but those things
are so fragile they like they're they're
so vulnerable like if an emergency
happens and everyone wants to call it
once the cell phone system can't handle
it yeah like it's not like you have a
phone and you can call anytime you want
and I have a phone I call anytime I want
and everyone in the world is a phone
they can call anytime they want know if
everybody does that the system is not
set up to handle that right if everybody
does it like ah like that's why if
there's an earthquake or tsunami
everyone's [ __ ] it's so hard to make
phone calls yeah it's not gonna get
through yeah well dude I just heard on
NPR that so many people were requesting
unemployment that it's crashed systems
in several states that's cuz this is a
real problem one of my friends was
saying he's like you know a lot of
people are running out of money tomorrow
they're bartenders anyone in the service
injury all the people who work at The
Comedy Store yeah it's not like I mean
how many of them had a lot of money like
stored up none of them so what what
happens now when there's no food on the
shelves no we got to help them
we're
we I've been a text message thread with
Whitney Cummings and Nick Swardson and
Chris D'Elia and we're talking about
that very thing right now I kind of do
it and how to set up a fund it needs to
be done for sure you know people that
can help should help this is not a
normal time this is not a time where
people are lazy this is a time where the
whole world got [ __ ] real quick yeah
yeah weren't ready for it and we're
gonna have to come together
[Applause]